SPEAKER: You can use
custom dashboards
to tailor the monitoring
experience to your environment.
To create your first
custom dashboard,
click Dashboards at the top
of the screen and Create.
Here, we'll add three
charts to our new dashboard.
First, I'll choose a resource
type of Google App Engine
Module.
And then I'll search
for latency metrics.
Here, I'll add the response
latency's 95th percentile.
So now I have a chart that
displays the 95th percentile
latency for each of
my App Engine modules.
I'll add a second chart for
the App Engine responses
for each of the modules.
So again, I'll type
Responses to filter the list.
And then I'll choose Total
Responses and click Save.
And I'll add a third chart
for Google Compute Engine
instances.
In this case, I'm primarily
interested in CPU usage
for each of my instances.
And I'll click Save.
So now I have three charts
on my custom dashboard.
I can also change the
layout of that dashboard.
Perhaps I want to view it
in a three-column view.
I can also rearrange the
charts on the dashboard
by clicking on any of
the titles and moving it
into its location.
If I want to look at the
dashboard in full screen mode,
I can click the Full Screen icon
in the top right-hand corner
of the screen.
This is particularly useful
for viewing the dashboard
on a large LED
screen in an office.
To the left of the
Full Screen icon,
you can access the
settings for the chart,
such as the setting to show all
of the legends on the charts.
And to the left of that, I can
choose to enable auto-refresh
for my charts.
And then if I've zoomed
in any of the charts
to a particular time
frame, I can always
use the Reset Zoom
icon to reset the time
frame across all of my charts.
And then finally, if I wanted
to choose a specific time
frame for the
charts, I can click
on any of the links in
the top right-hand corner
to view that time frame.
Here, I'm looking at
a day's worth of data
across all of my charts.
And so those are the core
capabilities of the Custom
Dashboard feature.
There are many more
capabilities for you
to take advantage of as
you familiarize yourself
with custom dashboards.